in some ways we are wired the same way
I'm not throwing elbows into Jose
Alvarado's chin
I'm not that type of bad angle there I'm
not nut punching Julius Hodge I'm not
doing that but
it's all love CP
JJ you know
I think I have done you and Tommy's show
three times and this is your first time
doing my show you did an iteration of
something for me yes but I'm very happy
that we are kind of switching a bit and
you are here I'm happy to be here thanks
for the invite absolutely well thanks
for doing me the favor
um but I was gonna start somewhere
totally different but you're now telling
me a story about Knox being a baller and
you potentially coaching please repeat
that story yeah so Knox my oldest did
not care about basketball while I played
and then he got really obsessed over the
last year so he started uh like doing
once a week clinics in the spring but
then we signed him up for this rec
league in September the rec league not
the best competition so we found him
another team to play simultaneously with
and uh he's had a few games and I went
to the coach last week and I said hey do
you mind if I help out when I'm here
obviously I'm doing games and stuff but
uh when I'm here I would love to help
out he's like absolutely so yesterday I
coached in my first game and after the
game the coach called me and said would
you be the head coach
so I guess you know I texted a bunch of
my friends and I was like I got my first
head coaching offer yesterday and I
accepted uh it's a it's an unpaid
position it's an unpaid position but so
JJ the head coach of what age group
they're eight
wow Real Deal yes this is going to be
fun it's gonna be awesome
um you know
I think teaching fundamentals is like
really important obviously but I think
the teaching the fundamentals of like
what it means to be on a team at a young
age
um I don't think that gets stressed
enough and so that's something I'm going
to focus on a little bit Yeah well this
is also what this might be your first
you know head coaching offer but you
very recently were asked about coaching
somewhere else yes in Boston yeah I got
randomly because again I'm not I don't
have like a coaching agent
um but I I've got some unsolicited
coaching offers over this uh past off
season and the Boston thing just
happened so quick you know it was like a
Thursday when the news broke by Friday I
was talking to Brad and by Sunday I was
playing golf with Joe so
with the table here
here so
what exactly did Brad say to you and
what exactly did Missoula say to you
well I'm not gonna you know I'm not
gonna get into the exact details but
look there was a a situation where
someone got suspended
I think it was five days before the
start of training camp so most coaches
that are available
um have already have a job yeah you know
what I mean um or their head coach
that's taking time off and um Joe's sort
of sliding into that interim position
um I think it was just like a unique
thing I was going up to Boston to be
clear that was already planned I was
going up to Boston to no my my friend
Ryan herger he throws this backyard
party every year with the food truck and
a band and I'd never been our kids are
the same age so I was going up there
anyways and anytime I take a trip I try
to get a round of golf in so Austin
Danny's son and I were
we're going to play on Sunday morning as
it was and then it just so happened that
Joe ended up being the fourth got it
okay if you don't want to tell the exact
detail
but
life is about timing
um I would love I mean I've talked
briefly about this on my podcast but I
would love to coach at some point
um I don't feel like the timing is right
right now and speaking of timing
we're at the end of the round we're
having lunch and I was like Joe by the
way when do I need to be in Boston and
for some reason my brain hadn't quite
grasped the fact that training camp was
starting this week that week and so he's
like uh Tuesday I need you there Tuesday
for the first practice and this was
Sunday afternoon and I'm like all right
I don't know if I can swing this
um yeah but to be clear I mean it seems
like these were conversations about when
I'd be there what it would look like
there was this part of you that did want
to potentially oh yeah I wouldn't have
again I told Brad and Joe this like I
wasn't wasting anybody's time like it
was something that I considered
um Chelsea had been out of town that
whole week prior so she got back and we
had a long conversation Sunday night
um and I think our family it's more
about like my family and my kids age and
what they're getting into and
um you know I mentioned to you we're
going through a renovation as well
I just signed contracts for the podcast
and ESPN and so it was just like the
timings doesn't feel right at this
particular moment
um but hopefully in the near future like
that's hopefully something's gonna
happen I would love to to coach in the
NBA what do you think is the thing about
JJ Redick that would make you a good
coach
um
I don't necessarily think it's one thing
but
I feel like I know the game pretty well
yeah I feel like because of some coaches
I played for it really specifically
Coach K like he taught me about
adaptability and our game the NBA
changes so fast year to year you could
be in an era and you think it's going to
be a 10-year era and it could be a year
or two and so just having the mindset of
my the the mindset of just being open to
change I think that's really good I
think
one of my greatest skills as a human
being is my ability to communicate and
communicate in an open and transparent
way and
I did that as a teammate
and I think that's part of coaching is
just not avoiding things and not
avoiding confrontation I
locker rooms team chemistry it's a very
fragile thing we see it all the time in
the NBA and the other part of it is like
I look at coaching as as a way to help
yeah and you know there's a competitive
part of it for sure that's a major
driving force
but uh
it's like I had so many people help me
in my career and not just head coaches
but assistant coaches Player Development
people
um and they have such a valuable place
in my in my heart and in my life and I'd
love to be one of those people someday
yeah I mean because you said I so much
of being a coach it isn't just about
like this in-game stuff it's not about
adjustments it's about being a manager
of people I think that's what really
makes great coaches great how they were
able to figure out this mesh of people
and make it work so when you look at the
coaches you've had who's been not the
best coach but just the best manager of
individuals
it's a great question
um
I think all my coaches did it well to a
certain degree they just did it in a
very different way Stan in particular
was very direct with everyone I mean
even early in my career there was a
little bit of this with me and him
um and I so I appreciate I really
appreciate that approach doc was great
about motivating people he's he's great
with words he's a great communicator
Brett had such a good soul and a such a
good heart and so when he said something
you knew he meant it
um and I those were the I think the
coaches that I primarily spent the most
time with as a player and and of course
coach I mean he's the only person I call
Coach yeah to be honest with you uh but
of course coach I mean he he I feel like
he's don't call him that he hears you
yeah I mean I couldn't imagine calling
him by his first name that would that
wouldn't go down well
in your whole life you've never called a
vice versa I never will no and I don't
I'll like occasionally say thanks coach
to someone else but when I refer to
people
that are not in the room it's like Brett
and Doc and stand yeah and then it's
coach yeah I mean I call my high school
coach Billy like that was his name Billy
I called him Billy you know he's still
Billy to me a coach is coach how do you
become that like the coach why is he the
one that you can't say his name it's I
just
some of it is
the level of respect because I grew up a
Duke fan and I was still pinching myself
when I would be in team meetings at Duke
you know it's still like holy [ __ ] this
is actually real this is not like my
dream I'm actually living this out so
the respect part is there
um
how he treated me
I always tell people like my dad is the
greatest man that I've ever known and my
dad is up here but then it's it's coach
like he's the second figure in my life
that has had an incredible impact and
influence really in what ways
um first of all he showed me what it
looked like to give people a second
chance he showed me what it looked like
to forgive
um because I honestly like I probably
should have been either suspended or
kicked off the team my sophomore year
and he wrapped his arms around me
instead and put me on a plan and that
plan that summer changed the course of
my life it changed the course of my
career
that's a big moment in your life and so
it's not that I feel in like indebted
it's just it it carries a lot of meaning
and weight and I'm grateful for that
um
the other thing is he he makes time he's
incredibly busy I was actually home for
Thanksgiving I was back in Raleigh my
parents and sisters lived there and I
had texted him earlier in the week and I
was like hey do you mind if I come over
I'd love to catch up so I went over to
his house on Saturday and
sat in his living room he's also got a
puppy by the way yeah
I just got a puppy uh very cute but you
know and just spending an hour and a
half with him it's just like he he had a
camp the day of my wedding and he got a
PJ out of his own pocket to fly down
stayed the whole time dance with the
grandmas got back on the PJ was back at
Camp the next morning like he just and
it's not just me that he's done this for
I've seen him do this for dozens and
dozens of Duke players
um so just I think we all Revere him
yeah we all Revere him no I remember
seeing you and Jason both talking about
him and you all were discussing these
funny moments right but it was all about
how is there this man that is so Grand
right but has all of these other things
and other reasons why we love him and
it's also personal and so many of you
guys have had a singular experience
which really speaks to who he is and
what he has done for and to everyone
which is really beautiful I also
for me
going back to the coaching thing I
um I've taken something from every coach
in some ways and with Coach I've taken a
lot but one of the things that always
stood out to me
was how invested he was meaning I never
saw him have a bad day that's not to say
he didn't
you know make mistakes he's not a
perfect person but I never saw him come
to work come to practice come to a game
with the wrong mindset or the wrong
attitude or the wrong energy like there
was always such intent and uh enthusiasm
for everything he was doing on every
single day I was around every day for
four years pretty much I never saw him
have a bad day and when I was a player
and certainly early on in my career
trying to figure things out I probably
went through some things but you know
once I figured out the NBA it was like
that I took great pride in that like I'm
gonna come to work today and I'm gonna
be super enthusiastic I'm going to be a
great teammate I'm going to be engaging
um I I mean I learned that from him yeah
yeah being solid and I think there's
something too being a person where
everybody knows what they're going to
get like regardless of the day I know
what I'm gonna get from this person and
those I think tend to be the people that
can kind of draw you to them in
different ways something you just
mentioned I have heard you mention it a
lot um in podcasts and different
articles is this sophomore year at Duke
and what it meant to your life what did
this year mean for you the good and the
bad yeah to sort of set the stage I grew
up a Duke fan had wanted to go there my
you know entire childhood uh teenage
years
um so it was like a dream and it came
true and then I get there and it's way
harder than I realized and it's way more
of a fishbowl than I realized and then
on top of that there's the um the
opposing teams fan bases that just hate
me and I just kind of felt like I was in
this spiral and I asked my sisters to
drive over from Raleigh in December of
my sophomore year
told them I wanted to quit told him I
want to just be a normal student
actually Paula Ben Caro talked about
this recently on a podcast where he felt
like when he was on campus and he was a
Duke basketball player it just felt like
everybody's eyes were on him and it's
weird because now having played 15 years
in the NBA I realize it's not the case
but when you're in that moment the the
Duke basketball experience feels so big
it feels so enormous and so I I kind of
rebelled I mean I was I was living like
a frat kid my sophomore year and on the
surface whatever I was 13 All-American
second Team all ACC leading scorer on
the final four team like I had a good
season but it wasn't it wasn't right and
and coach said to be in a series of
meetings after uh we lost to UConn in
the final four he made me come in like
every Saturday during April at 8 A.M and
he said to me we didn't win a National
Championship because you weren't worthy
and I wasn't prepared to hear that and
because it cut me so deep so I spiraled
even more more and it got to the point
where I had not gone to class that
semester either so I had an incomplete
that I had to finish summer school had
started I told my parents I was
finishing the incompleted Duke I told
Duke I was back in Roanoke finishing
really I was just hanging out at a
buddy's apartment and and that's you
know I get here on the door and Wojo and
Collins are there they dragged me to
campus and I go up to coach's office and
that meeting literally that moment
changed my life and Coach Collins said
something in that meeting that has
really stuck with with me he said you
know the sad thing is we'll never know
how good you could be
and
the the two of them you are not we were
not Champions because you were not
worthy of being a champion and the sad
thing is we'll never know how good you
can be those two things it stuck with me
the rest of my career like I'm not
you're not going to be able to say that
about me I'm gonna work relentlessly and
the support system I had at Duke that
summer they put me on a plan like I'd
still have a sheet printed out of
you know wake up time check-in time
class time workouts I had three workouts
a day bedtime
um when I would when I would eat
um and so yeah and then I became known
for the routine it was because I didn't
have a routine before that I was just
making [ __ ] up yeah so how much of that
hard time and how much of this kind of
Crisis within yourself about you know
being at Duke and figuring out who you
are how much that was compounded by
literally feeling like everyone hated
you it was definitely compounded by it
um it would have been hard no matter
what
when you're 18 or 19 your your ego
structure your sense of self your
security and self it's just not there
and I had a really hard time with that I
I wanted people to like me like if that
was important to me like it is for
almost any 18 or 19 year old person and
so
dealing with this like the things that
were said about me even just like the
there was like a a sick sense of joy in
going to an opposing Arena and have
everybody yell at you and then you know
having 25 points and winning the game
like there's a I kind of got off on it a
little bit but but also like then all of
a sudden the high the high leaves you
and you're left reflecting and you're
that's a question you can't answer like
why why does everybody hate me yeah I'm
18 years old why does it you know and so
that made it way worse way worse than
just the normal Duke experience and I
mean it really was I remember articles
talking about you being like the worst
person on earth like it was a big thing
like everybody wanted to not like JJ
Redick I assume now because of who you
are you have gotten over it mostly are
you fully over that moment in your life
I'm I'm over it it's one of the reasons
I can talk about it openly
um and again I you know I saw mental
health professionals sophomore year on
um I became very comfortable in that
setting and so
I continue to do that throughout my MBA
career at different points in time
um you know I I have no problem seeking
help you know and and so
I'm
I'm just I think it's that period
especially at Duke is like figuring out
who I am and being comfortable with that
like I can admit I'm an [ __ ] like I'm
a sarcastic prick and I that's okay like
it doesn't make me a bad person yeah I
know it's funny because I'm like okay I
wonder if JJ Redick now how you would
have felt about that JJ red I get the
time oh oh I would have hated that kid
you're like I hear you guys I see it I'm
like I get it I get it I get it the head
bobbing the The Smiling just the it was
really annoying I was really annoying
you know I get it I get it in a Vanity
Fair article you talked about just this
Arc that your career has gone just
explain that art to me the points in
that Arc
um
so I don't remember exactly what I said
in that article but I do remember
telling Eve who who wrote the article
she was wonderful to to talk to
um
like I'm not I'm not comfortable with
people saying oh I like JJ Redick now
like it doesn't that doesn't like make
me feel better or anything like that I
think it's like sort of just
wanting to keep an even Keel with other
people's perceptions of you is if that
makes sense so I don't necessarily view
it in this Arc but the the general
thought is that I when I first started
playing at Duke everybody hated me early
in my NBA career everybody hated me and
they they loved it I was failing and
then I worked my way into the rotation I
gained people's respect and then in the
end it turns out that I'm not so bad
yeah it is uh again that's that's sort
of the general sense I get from other
people but how has your experience
changed the way that you talk about
other athletes because I'm sure there
are times where you have this inkling of
okay I kind of don't like this person
but you don't really know why and you
think maybe that's what people thought
about me
well there's
when I talk about athletes there's sort
of two ways to do that you can talk
about
output
meaning what they're doing on the court
the productivity how that fits into
winning
that's fairly easy to talk about
the Nuance of talking about the human
which is something that I think you do
very well and something that we try to
do on the podcast as well
I think that gets complicated especially
not knowing someone
did that make sense so if I if I know
someone if I've been someone's teammate
I'm just gonna avoid it because that's
sort of against the code you know what I
mean
um but if I don't know that person and
I'm asked to and I certainly have to get
out I have to talk about certain people
I think I think sort of viewing that
through
what happened to me it's like all right
I've got to be sort of delicate and
sometimes like even
I'll gather information you know I'll
talk to people around the league hey
what's this guy actually really like
like is what's this locker room what's
sort of dividing this locker room
um I'm not gonna like
quote somebody on that but it just it's
information gathering yeah well so what
last week we had Chuck on the show and
he was telling me the story about how he
said something about Michael Jordan on
air they haven't talked for 10 years
because of it that was his best friend
he's saying it's been something that's
been very very difficult for him how do
you toe that line and have there been
times where you've had to talk about
somebody that you're close to but it's
made you a little hesitant because of
how they would receive it yeah I think
there's been there's been two times
that I wish I had handled differently
um the first one was with Zion last year
when
uh
CJ McCollum had given an interview at
All-Star break and they asked about what
him and Zion had talked about and CJ
said
I haven't spoken with Zion
which I thought was strange CJ had
played five games with the Pelicans at
that point and again I I think I called
him
um like oh I can't remember the exact
wording but as a teammate I said you
know he kind of distances himself or
whatever which is something that I said
design when I was his teammate it wasn't
like this the first day but it wasn't
like just saying it publicly but I wish
I'd handle that differently and I
probably could have just avoided it all
together if I really wanted to
um and then there was something else
recently you know
talking about a team and um
and I probably got some information
wrong and one of the players reached out
to me and we had a nice chat about it
and that was that so I think I think
that's the challenge perk you know perk
and I have talked about this and perk I
think spoke on this when he came on my
podcast like it is it is hard and I will
readily admit like I am so Pro player
that it borders on bias I will admit
that and I'm Pro this generation of
player I will admit that
um
but it's formed by my own experience of
of playing against these guys of I'm not
an historian of the NBA but I certainly
study the NBA I study I spent like weeks
last summer watching um
like old 1960s finals games on YouTube
and 80s finals games on YouTube I'm like
am I crazy for thinking this about
today's player let me go back yeah let
me see all right plumbers I'm just
kidding but I I I I'm so but you're
you're often asked to talk uh and
presented with a situation especially on
first take
um where it's not just about
uh did this player shoot the ball well
or uh is this player causing this team
to lose you're you're asked to talk
about things that can often be very
personal and
that's a challenge and I promise you
that as long as I'm doing this I go into
everything with the right intention I'm
gonna [ __ ] up like I know I am like
there's nobody has bad at a thousand in
media there's not a person not one human
being but I wonder too how sustainable
you feel like that is because I think
that is one of your powers is that you
are pro player people feel comfortable
talking to you because they know that
you understand but for how long can you
be that yeah it's a good question
um
it's something that I can get frustrated
with sometimes because
we do live in a world where clicks
matter
and
people respond to incentives and so if
the incentive is a click
most people I'm not saying everyone but
most people at some point are going to
respond to that incentive meaning
they're going to say things or do things
for clicks
um
I don't go on first take I don't do a
podcast with the intent of clicks
certainly I want positive feedback we
all do
but I go into the intent with trying to
be as authentic as I can possibly be
and that
can sometimes drive one group of people
to feel a certain way and another group
of people feel a different way yeah and
that's the nature of the game I've
accepted it it's all good yeah you know
so in terms of how sustainable it is to
be a pro player
like I think the people the fans I think
people who are commenting on Twitter or
watching First Take and disagreeing with
things I think they are so biased at
times yeah they're set and whatever they
think that they're so set so nothing I'm
going to say is going to change their
mind yeah it's in some ways I'm not
comparing the two but in some ways it is
like politics right yeah it is yeah you
know the people that are sitting there
oh great take today yeah it's because
you already believed what I just said
yeah and the people who said you're an
idiot that's because you
think something else completely
different there's nothing is changing in
those three minutes yeah I totally agree
uh have you ever had something go viral
from your podcast that you're like damn
I feel bad that my Bible I've had plenty
but I just I wonder if you're like that
is not what I wanted this too and then
you feel bad for the player because they
said it on you it's like it's a whole
thing I'll be honest with you I can
think of one example and I gave him
every out I'll be honest with you there
are times and it's not often but
we've done 137 episodes on The Old Man
and the three
I've made
five or six edits
without telling the guest I was going to
make these edits because I felt like I
had to protect them a little bit really
so I just don't put it in
we had one player early on give it give
it an interview the juiciest part of the
interview
was a story that nobody knows it's
[ __ ] hilarious but it put him in a
tough position and so his team reached
out can you cut the story we cut the
story now with perk this [ __ ]
said he was praying for the Bronx
to tear his ACL crazy and I was like
perk we're gonna cut that and he no
you're not going to cut it you're not
going to cut it they need to understand
how crazy LeBron was making me you know
so I was like all right we'll leave it
in we'll leave it in really that's
interesting making that decision to cut
it for them
um
yeah I it somewhat has to do with my own
experience as a player
um so
if it's not additive like honestly when
the player asked us to cut the story it
was the best part of the entire
interview
I honored it uh and we very well easily
could have put it in there we could have
kept it in there
um
but I felt like that was an additive
thing to the story so if it's not
additive and it's just going to cause a
fan base or a group of people to be
pissed off like I don't I don't need to
do that yeah no and that's fair I think
I think that makes sense did you ever
think you know you would be sitting down
to do interviews in the first like 15
minutes would be about you as a media
member and not
and not about JJ Redick uh Sharpshooter
even you know when I YouTube JJ Redick
it's not basketball highlights that come
up it's just your podcast I know my my
oldest is very confused by that yeah
he's like are you sure you played
basketball you got to be very specific
when you type in my name because he
loves like he's on YouTube every day so
I'm like when you're very specific when
you type in my name you have to add the
word highlights otherwise it's just
going to be the podcaster first take
okay so if
if highlights came up right what is the
Highlight you would want people to see
of JJ Redick the basketball player
the the easy answer the one that comes
up the most so the Duke Instagram
accounts are not necessarily the
official ones but just like Duke fan
accounts Duke Twitter accounts or
whatever the Texas game comes up a lot
and I don't know how many views that has
on YouTube
um but that's one but I'm like I'm
really proud of my like Duke career
don't get me wrong I'm so proud of it
I'm more proud of my NBA career yeah
um because I understand
now that I'm on the other side uh how
ridiculous it was that I got to play 15
years in the NBA and I just you know out
somebody was asking me this other day
outside of winning a championship
and being an All-Star
and I only need those things once I
didn't need them nine times I just I
tell you those two things like I did way
more than I ever expected in the NBA so
NBA it's not it's not my 40-point game
against Houston which was my career high
we'll make sure we say that I think it's
like I think it's probably like a random
game
in Charlotte or something where I had
like
like 27 10 and 8. okay yeah you're like
I could no I no because I'm like and I
think I don't know if that was the game
in Charlotte where I had a little Lefty
reverse layup but
there's there was a little bit of sauce
it didn't come out much and it wasn't
highly seasoned but I had a little sauce
I mean you talk about doing you know all
these things in the NBA that you
probably never really thought your
career would be and I in 2005 you did an
interview with I think the Charlotte
Observer and they're talking about what
you want your career to look like and
you say oh well I'm just going to be a
role player and I don't know if most NBA
players or MBA prospective players would
have like would be able to say okay I
don't think I'm gonna be a star
because that's the thing that you hope
to be how did you have kind of I guess
that presence of mind to know this is
what you thought would happen
some of it is because I try to be
realistic yeah and some of it was coach
um something he always talked about was
Broadway shows I know that sounds weird
but he said if you go to a Broadway show
uh let's say you go once and you're like
oh my God that show is amazing if you
went a second time and you really
thought what makes that show amazing
maybe it's the lead and maybe it's their
voice and their singing the lyrics right
but what makes a great show what makes a
great team what makes a great product is
everyone starring in their role so go to
a Broadway show and watch the person
that doesn't have any speaking Parts
who's dancing in the third row of The
Ensemble like there's totally invested
in that scene
and he talked about that with our own
team like your role may change year to
year but if you're starring in that role
you have value and so
even with my son every NBA fan it's like
if you're not a top five player you're a
bum it's a very weird phenomenon
um and so Knox will ask me about is this
he'll be is this player good and I'm
like yeah he's good he's in the NBA he's
like well how good and I'm like I don't
know Knox and he's like was he an
All-Star and I have it's I literally
have this conversation with him seven
times a week Knox there's all stars and
there's all NBA guys and then there's
like 70 players yeah that in the right
moment with the right fit could be an
All-Star mm-hmm there's that many good
players so yes Knox Mikhail Bridges is
good
how do you think got here though where
that's how we discussed what a player
was
um people like Liz
yeah we like lists and everything you
know what are the best restaurants in
New York Taylor you're gonna give me a
list yeah who are the best players
you're going to give me a list people
like lists people like they're it's like
a Michelin star it's like oh are we sure
that restaurant's good it doesn't have a
Michelin star it only got 7.2 at the
infatuation it's like we're just that's
where it says but this is what this is
how human beings operate and so it's
like if I go on a basketball reference
page and I don't see all NBA All-Star
multiple times like well that guy wasn't
that good and
that's not true I mean I I think about
different guys
um somebody said the other day somebody
asked on Twitter the other day something
about which player would you want to see
in today's NBA and I said pagia
like Pages like an overlooked OG Legend
to me I think he was so awesome the
answer I would not yeah but he would he
would kill he would kill in today's NBA
not that he didn't kill in his own
career but
um so yeah we just
we think because a guy and this goes
back to ring culture too which is a very
complicated thing did you watch by any
chance did you watch uh Hassan minhaja's
episode with me that we did he had this
solid two right we did this is the one
we did with Brad it was the Bradley Beal
episode two months ago but no I think I
watched the first yes yes so the most
recent one he had this really insightful
I thought I think profound take on
winning and how we view winning
and the cost of winning and sort of the
maniacal approach that you have to take
to win and be a champion and we applaud
that I'm not saying it shouldn't be
applauded but there are different forms
of winning and he used Steve Kerr as a
as an example and Steve Cruz obviously
won championships but when you talk
about his relationships with his family
his his lifestyle the respect that
people have for him like that guy's that
guy's one he called him the ultimate
winner from the Chicago Bulls teams I
thought that was fascinating yeah and
and I Dame has talked about this a ton
too right yeah you can't tell me Damien
Lillard is not a [ __ ] winner totally
and yeah yes he doesn't have a ring but
I would I would say that guy's a
champion yeah he's a champion yeah yeah
and he has so much respect if ever in
League everybody likes Dame he's one of
the best teammates he's kind he has a
beautiful family I think that is fair
and makes a lot of sense but when I
think about how we view these players I
actually do sort of think about your
career because what you were drafted
11th overall right but those first three
years of your career I think it's fair
to say it was a bit of a struggle but
then now we see you as one of the most
prolific Shooters of all time and I say
that to say I wonder if we don't give
players now enough time to become who
they're supposed to be yeah because say
you came what five years later there's a
good chance you're not JJ Redick
I think if I come five years later
I'm probably have a better career but I
mean he had to get there like in that
situation you had to get there though
yeah because you they went the other
interesting thing I got I got lucky in
this sense because I was not a good NBA
player my first two years and I didn't
shoot well my third year but at that
time like I felt confident that I was a
rotation level player
um I was 22 when I was drafted like it
wasn't like I was 19 and so the magic
we're really patient with me
um I worked
um I figured out how to sort of fit on
that team and and play a role on that
team that's stand valued
um it was a great learning experience
but we don't we don't give enough time
for judgment calls I think this is not a
thing that exists we're also I'm guilty
of this as well
I think
we all want players to like make that
jump that leap the proverbial jump from
role player to star or Star to Superstar
and sometimes it just takes time and
Jason Tatum is a great example like him
not making all NBA his fourth year and
that whole I remember I remember the
discourse around that and the Celtics
struggled that year I think they ended
up with the a7c maybe something like
that but they were around 500 and
Jason counting numbers wise had a good
year but it was like that he was a
disappointment almost right in a
disappointing season and then comes back
makes First Team all NBA top five in NBA
voting now is two years after that is
you know I think the clear front runner
right now for MVP and so sometimes it
that that leap just takes time
sometimes players Maybe
never going to become a star and that's
okay yeah there's a lot of examples of
players that were drafted very high that
never made the jump to Star but are now
in their Jeff Green he's in his like
16th year or whatever it is now he's
carved out a great career he's won he's
won yes and I think that it's placing
too much of that weight on the actual
literal winning being a trophy and it
makes us really sometimes I don't like
the way that we do talk about players
because I don't think that that patience
exist I think that we expect players to
be who we think they were supposed to be
and we aren't giving them time to like
fill in those gaps and it's very
dangerous for players right because it
affects their self-esteem but it also
changes the way that we value life and
people because everything is just like a
commodity that has either like it's
about to expire or it still tastes good
and there's like no in between of those
things yes
I'll give you the I'll give you an
in-between of that and and actually I
went a Pablo Torre from ESPN daily he's
you know you know him he's awesome but
we did a podcast on sort of mental
health versus mental toughness and um
I I think this sort of in between is
just kind of acknowledging that some
players just aren't
built
a certain way mentally and and that's
okay yeah you know and it doesn't mean
they're less of a human or player it's
just they're not
they're missing it and and it's like
some guys just they're they're never
gonna get it and that's okay that's okay
but I think the criticism of that
is what we signed up for
so yes I don't want to be dehumanized as
an athlete I don't want to dehumanize
other athletes
but the criticism and the critique
it's part of the job
why we get paid because there's millions
of people that watch us and critique us
and talk about us and
want to join the discourse and it's part
of it and you just kind of have to
accept that yeah would you say the
majority of guys in the NBA actually do
not handle criticism well because I
would say that
here's my question who does this is
where I'm like who does handle no I
disagree I think that when there is
something constructive being said I will
take that and I know you will too
I'm talking about I think that a lot of
guys don't like here don't like hearing
that they're not the best
that type of criticism
yeah
not that you haven't been criticized
publicly Taylor but I think the constant
public criticism can weigh on you a
little bit so I think that's an element
of it I also think that uh there's this
weird I I'm Gonna Knock players here and
I I there's this weird like the haters
right it's like I want to prove the
haters wrong or I have so many haters
and you're just like
dude LeBron James LeBron is
arguably okay let's just say he's top
two player of all time let's just say
that okay okay he's top two player of
all time let's say that actually we'll
just say I don't want to offend anybody
we're gonna say he's on the Mount
Rushmore of NBA players he's the top
four all right
at the least
he's top four
LeBron James has as many if not more
haters than any NBA player to ever exist
yeah
yeah it's like this is this is the and
and truthfully there are people driving
that public people in media that are
driving that a little bit but
um it's just
part of the last 20 years especially I
think specifically the last 13 to 14
years with social media it's just it's
what we what is what we do and it's what
we signed up for it's it's fine yes and
I am agreeing with you but I think that
not everybody views it in that way I
think that some athletes take criticism
that isn't like rough it's just not them
being the best and they take it
incredibly personally there's been so
many times that like someone has reached
out about like the thing that I said
even if it wasn't bad like I didn't say
anything rude or disrespectful who knows
maybe I'll write it in my book one day
but I didn't see anything rude or
disrespectful I just didn't say that
they were this specific thing
it's a heart the Superstar thing here we
go I don't I'm not saying who or what or
what we're talking about I'm not saying
who or what we're talking about
I just wonder because you like listening
it's a very excuse because you like less
and it's like because you like to
categorize things I was actually asked
about but here's a question shout out to
Jason here's here's a question though I
know I know
the question though
let's I'm gonna put my myself in a
yeah in a player's position like
what do I value
so
I think it's human nature for you to be
valued or to be categorized in a certain
way and to value that
so if something
like an All-Star and how important that
is I think Rudy goberry when he got
first got named in All-Star he cried
right it was that important when he
didn't know when he did he started he
cried when he was maybe he cried both
times I don't think he cried the second
one but the first time other players
that have cried he wasn't named and he
was that's right that's right he cried
that's right so that that was clearly
important to him as it should be yeah
right it's it's
you you want to be recognized and it's
important
um
but I think placing too much value
on those categories or those lists I
don't think that's necessarily a healthy
way to live
I know going back to Duke like it seems
small now
I was the leading scorer on the ACC
Championship team and my conference
numbers were better and I was the sixth
leading vote getter for All Conference
that year so I was on the second team
and like I was [ __ ] pissed I was
pissed had I made first team
my season was still shitty it's like it
was still a shitty season yeah
so it's just it's a small example but I
I think and Coach used to I remember
even going into that year we met before
every season and going that year I like
brought this piece of paper and it was
like uh first female American ACC player
of the year it was like all these win a
championship you know all the all the
all the goals I wanted to to do and he's
like
he's like let me ask you a question have
you done anything noteworthy this off
season to actually achieve these goals
and I like I left so dejected because
you're like no I haven't now the
following the following year was 215
220ish when my season ended uh my
sophomore year I'd go into preseason at
192 I've won every conditioning drill
um I'm killing in every single pickup
game because I had worked on my game all
summer and I go in there and I didn't
even have any goals I was just like I'm
just gonna go and I'm gonna play but
like you can't say that about me this
year right you'll never say that about
me ever again that I didn't do the work
to achieve something
um so yeah I I mean I I think the
category part in the list part
I think that matters
um but how much value you're placing on
that that's why we get sensitive that's
why we get sensitive fair and hey yeah
I'm Sensitivity I think everyone every
everyone has the right to feel what they
want to feel Taylor I'm [ __ ]
sensitive as [ __ ]
that's in the wrong moment that's fair I
did some like you know I don't I
want
a big part of it is I don't want anyone
ever feel bad about something I said
like that genuinely is a big part of it
because you know a lot of your job is
your opinion it's asking questions
having discussion and it's never coming
from malicious place at least for me I'm
not going to speak for every media
member but so I'm always thinking like I
don't want somebody to feel as though
their like worth is being questioned
because I said something because in the
grand scheme of it who Am I who cares
really but I I
in the last year since I've become part
of the media I don't
I've been accused of like protecting a
player like I don't think players should
be protected like if a criticism is fair
and it's just then criticized and say it
taking your agenda out on someone is a
very different thing definitely it's a
very different thing and we talk about
bias in media and like again I am biased
because of my experience we are all
biased to a degree because of our
experience or in some cases our
knowledge right if we don't have all the
information we may inherently be a
little biased yeah for sure that's just
how it works okay so in your MBA career
a criticism you heard of yourself that
stuck with you
the defense thing for sure I mean
um
that that
because there I had to I was never going
to rebound I just not I'm not a good
defensive rebounder so I was never going
to rebound and I I because of Stan
specifically in our our schemes there
like I never was going to gamble on
defense and so I didn't get a lot of
deflections or Steals and I didn't
defensive rebound well but like I was a
good Defender for a number of years but
like RPM wouldn't rate me well because I
didn't get deflections I have short arms
right defense thing now at the end of my
career please hide me yeah I can't do
anything on this I don't my first year
in New Orleans like we we I I call this
team meeting and like it was just kind
of we had lost a number of games in a
row I think I think we lost like
double-digit games in a row and this was
like halfway through the streak but I
like called this meeting and I'm like
all right guys like we're going to talk
this out as a team we're gonna be real
with each other and be honest with each
other and so like I said a few things to
guys and I'm like yeah my defense sucks
and I'm like guys I can't do it anymore
I'm admitting to you like I can't go
lock up Devin Booker not that I ever
could but please hide me
uh so that's one thing the other part
about the other part about being a a
shooter a great shooter uh and not just
me I mean it's every every guy people
look at that so much and they don't
value all the other things you do
and you know I I never was a high volume
pick and roll guy I think you know my
last half of my career I was always in
the 99th percentile and pick and rolls
like never got any credit for that not
that I wanted it
I was never gonna be a primary playmaker
but you know I that was a damn good
pocket passer I'll be honest with you
you know if I had the right two-man game
you know Joelle Zion Blake
um so like you you're you're again I'm
never gonna get credit for that stuff
it's fine I'll be a shooter who couldn't
play defense and I'm like okay yeah but
I played 15 years so I must have been
doing other things yeah absolutely okay
so 15 seasons in the NBA which season
were you the happiest
hmm
there's
it's weird because
the seasons that stand out a lot of it
has to do with the group yeah and not
necessarily something that I did
um that's fine and it also a little bit
has to do with
the point in your life you're at so I
think about 2010 a lot and we had made
the finals in 09 that was a magical year
and it was awesome
um but like personally for me it was
very meaningful because it was the first
year I didn't get any dnp CDs
I played in every game that year and I
knew I was going to be in the rotation
every night and this that was like and
we won 59 games we made it to the
Conference Finals
um my first time being a teammate with
Matt Barnes Jay Jay will was there
um white chocolate so like it was just
an awesome year
um got engaged got married that that
year over the course that year so like
that year means a lot
um those first two years with the
Clippers
um
even though I was like I didn't have a
great year my first year I played 35
games I broke my wrist tore ligament my
wrist I had a herniated disc in my back
that caused nerve damage in my leg
um we ended up [ __ ] on the bed again
so okay see you in the second round so
like there's a lot of things that went
wrong that year but it was my first year
with those guys I like became Chris
Paul's friend that year you know I
became DJ's friend that year that was a
that was an amazing year Knox was born
that year uh the following year was
awesome that was you know one of my best
personal seasons and it obviously ended
poorly but like our group those two
years was so tight it was great uh and
then my my first year in Philly because
that was leaving La uh new situation
Brett empowered me so much to lead that
group and again I got to play with Joe I
got to play with Ben I got to play in
Philly it was magic we had a 16-game
winning streak so those are the Four
Seasons that that stand out the most
um I I enjoyed I enjoyed all of it like
I I do you guys understand like
I would get stressed out you know I if
if you're going through a shooting slump
if you're on a losing streak I I did
play on a couple bad teams yeah I was in
the playoffs a lot of times like I was
on bad teams a couple times and like
it's very stressful I was never
ungrateful I was I enjoyed every day of
work even when it was hard and even it
was stressful I loved it all I really
did maybe not the first two years not in
Orlando the rest of it that Clippers
team is so fascinating to me because
there were so many personalities I mean
you talk about having to manage people I
can't even imagine that one and so you
talk about Chris Paul I know there's so
many of you discussed at length I know
Chris I think Chris is great he's super
kind he's been nothing but good to me
but people hate Chris Paul
and I don't know if they've ever really
spoken to somebody who knows Chris Paul
well so what is it that you would say
about Chris Paul and why you think he
tends to be misunderstood
yeah
um we hated each other in college we
both talked about that openly before so
that's to each other to each other about
each other it did different articles
when you get on the team together are
you like okay we gotta talk about how we
really [ __ ] hate each other because
we have to get past it so we we he
resigned uh and then a few other guys
resigned Darren Collison signed a
one-year deal and then I signed a
four-year deal so we had this press
conference and it was really the first
time that we sort of had talked uh we
had I think texted during free agency
but it was like so brief it wasn't a
real conversation so we talked there and
like I was kind of like I don't know how
this is going to go like is he is he
gonna be an [ __ ] to me like he's been
an [ __ ] to be by by entire existence
of knowing him
um and we both had gotten invited to
Brandon bass's wedding that summer so
Brandon was my teammate
um in Orlando originally then again with
the Clippers later on
but so we go to Houston and
I like saw him walking in the hotel I
was we were sitting you know I think we
were in the restaurant or whatever so I
texted him I was like you had Brandon's
wedding he's like yeah I was like come
down when you're ready Chelsea and I are
just waiting to go so so he came down
and we chatted for like two hours and it
was like oh I'm gonna really like this
guy I'm gonna really like this guy in in
some ways we are wired the same way
um I'm not throwing elbows into Jose
Alvarado's chin
I'm not that type of bad angle there I'm
not nut punching Julius Hodge I'm not
doing that but
it's all love CK it is all love CP oh
but yeah that's a bad angle on that
video Chris and I we we could we could
yell at each other this is why we could
yell at each other
we could disagree with each other on the
court and then we could go get dinner
after the game it was never personal
because I understood
that he just wanted to win and he
understood that I just wanted to win
yeah
um and so because of that we got along
really well and became very close
friends but when did you know like okay
we're friends like not just we sat in
this Lobby for two hours and we spoke
Scandal the television show yeah you
bonded over a scandal we would him and
Jada would invite Chelsea and I over
every week to watch Scandal and we'd go
and we'd sit in this theater room we'd
pour a glass of wine and we'd watch
Scandal that is hope for like weeks and
weeks and weeks yeah
[Laughter]
wow what were you team Fitz like where
where did you stand on that and where
did Chris stand oh my God you're asking
such specific questions about so much
has happened in my life since that show
was popular
good show I can't even remember the
third season plot to be honest yeah it
was a good show it was highly
entertaining it was a good show but then
it kind of started to get a bit too
crazy and I was like this isn't
realistic most shows golf yeah like what
this happened okay biggest regret or
what do you regret more
getting LeBron's ankles and missing the
shot
or even thinking that you could stop
LeBron and it ended up in you bleeding
definitely the ankle breaker yeah I mean
that's a career highlight moment lost
yeah it's gonna say it's not a highlight
it's not I
I hate when
you guys are probably guilty of this at
Bleacher Report and I'm sorry but I hate
when Instagram and Twitter accounts show
ankle breakers are a crazy pass and the
shot doesn't go in you got to make it it
drives me insane yeah I'm actually very
proud of that charge because
not many people would stand in the way
of LeBron James on a fast break and just
take it
um so yeah I
I know I've talked about this before but
like it drives me crazy because Knox and
Kai my youngest they just they give they
give me [ __ ] for missing that shot
against LeBron do you have a moment
against LeBron that you are very proud
of not the charge
um there was a game
in Philly during our big win streak so
this was 18. that was the team that he
sort of took to the finals they
obviously lost to Kevin Durant and Steph
Curry and the Warriors but during that
streak we played in Philly and
like we were our motion offense and
cutting and I just I had a big first
half and we were up like 30 and he
brought him all the way back and then I
hit two big shots down the stretch so
that was that was like a good that was a
good moment you can hold that close yeah
okay good a couple more people before we
close out I do want to read this quote
to you because I thought it was really
beautiful you said I wanted to be really
great at something I won to win I don't
know how you win in media but I'll
figure it out what have you figured out
I've
yeah it's a great question
you know to Taylor from being honest
there's um
and it's only because I had this
conversation with a friend of mine uh
who lives in the in the Bay Area and I
called the Warriors game
two and a half weeks ago
um so we had dinner the night before and
we were talking about
the competitive side of sport and how
it's hard to find that that same
competition
in Media
and I've reflected a lot on our
conversation over the last two weeks and
when you
are an athlete and and you get to the
highest level of your sport it's one of
the reasons I can't watch college sports
anymore it's very hard for me to do I
watch the NFL I watch baseball whatever
but I'm like
when you get to the highest level of
your sport and you get to compete in
that and you certainly lose you
certainly win you have good nights you
have bad nights
all of it is a drug
it's a drug the high you get from
winning a playoff game on the road or
hitting a big shot down the stretch to
close a team out and getting back to the
locker room it's a drug
I haven't found anything
that hits the same yeah and I don't know
if I ever will and I don't know if any
athlete ever will
I don't and there's certainly ways to
I I find incredible fulfillment from
being
more present with my kids and with my
wife and now our puppy I find incredible
fulfillment from that
but the the Fulfillment of competition
that I got to experience as an NBA
player
maybe I just have to accept like it it
won't ever happen for me in that same
way
um because that drug hits man it really
does when when I was talking to Chuck on
the show and he talked about when you
stopped playing basketball he said that
it was traumatizing is that the word
that you would use
I wouldn't use that word I
again my my current uh mental health
coach and therapist that I have been
talking to for the better part of three
years he really helped me through
retirement
um and I got to a great place with it
there are times
um actually I had it this week in Dallas
um I don't even know if I don't know if
I was such a meaningless player at that
point that it wasn't even a big deal but
we had a game Saturday Sunday
and home games this was during the year
where I was away from my family so I'd I
saw my family three times in eight
months and prior to that had missed two
months with them in the bubble so my
family came in for the weekend
and uh
uh Rick knew that so Rick called me
after shoot around and said hey I don't
think we're gonna put you in the
rotation tonight
on the in the first game but I plan on
putting you in the rotation tomorrow
night because it's second out of the
back to back we'll probably have a
couple guys sit out
um know your family's here don't want
you to feel embarrassed uh you're more
than welcome to just go to dinner with
them instead I know you missed them
which was an incredible thing to do and
I thanked him profusely
so I went to dinner with them it was at
Ocean Prime very close to my apartment
which I also have to be close to the
hotel where all the teams stay so I was
calling the Dallas game this over the
weekend and I
walked from my hotel up to where the
teams stay and I walked past the Ocean
Prime and I started crying like because
I remembered that moment and how
humiliating it was not that Rick
humiliated me but just that feeling like
as a competitive athlete of like there's
nothing I can do to help my team win
tonight it's like I'm that and there's
been different points over the last year
and change since I've retired that
yeah those moments hit you and it's not
it's not trauma it's just
I think Chuck was the same way I think
most athletes that have long careers are
you put so much you invest so much it's
not just time and physical exertion it
is literally all of your emotions all of
your mental capacity into something
and then it's just gone yeah you're
gonna have moments where you're like
[ __ ] man yeah that sucked or [ __ ] that
was awesome I wish I could get that
again but I think that's such a good
point because there is the time that you
announce you're retiring
but then there's the time that you know
you're gonna retire and those are not
the same time
you know what I mean and your time might
have been notion for like it that might
have been when you were like oh well I
actually actually had that thought this
weekend because I'm like I'm looking
back I'm like how did I not know right
then and there like I should have
retired the next day I should have just
been like I'm good
um
I knew I knew going into the last year
because retirement to be truthful like
as soon as we started having kids and I
started missing time and as they started
getting older I'm like all right I want
to keep playing and even my 14th year I
had a great season for the Pelicans and
my last game of the Bubble at 31 trying
to Stave off elimination from the from
the playing thing so like I it's like I
just in some of it was physically my
injuries like I just dropped off a cliff
but my spirit was broken that last year
um and I can remember the moment and I
had gone to that year being like I think
this is my last year
um
and I told David Griffin that is one of
the reasons I was like New Orleans knows
it's my favorite City literally in the
country and my favorite place I've ever
lived uh but I I was like I need to be
home my son is starting kindergarten
it's time for my family to have some
sort of priority and
we go to Tampa first to play the Raptors
in the pre in the opening game of the
the season and I had a great game I had
23 points it's two big three actually I
had four threes in the fourth quarter
but two big threes down the stretch
including an and one from the corner and
I'm like jazz I'm like picking up right
where I left off from the bubble and we
go to Miami next Christmas Eve is off we
have the early game at 12 p.m I wake up
that morning my wife has sent me a video
of Kai my youngest running downstairs to
the Christmas tree and I broke and that
was it and I never ever had any desire
after that I'm not good enough to
halfway through it I just my spirit was
gone
and I mean I talked to my parents on New
Year's I thought about driving back from
New Orleans like it was just so
yeah it like that part of it
that part of it I've had to sort of
reflect on and there's a sense of like
guilt because I'm like man I've [ __ ]
let my teammates down that year and I I
have a built-in excuse because I had an
Achilles injury but but I was I was dog
[ __ ] for like a month after that like I
think if you looked up my stats the next
seven games I was one for six on average
I start 7 42 over a seven game stretch
at no point in my career did I ever I
mean I had some bad stretches but like
seven years
over seven games
um that's bad yeah that's bad
um well I mean going off that I do kind
of want to give a final thought and
someone that I know is a dear friend of
both of ours is Sue bird because I think
that the way she retired was perfect and
she did it like on her terms when it
felt right to her and her way she had
her moment with the fans and I'm like
she was so lucky and also so intentional
and so smart to be able to have that
ride that she was able to have in the
end does that make sense 100 and
part of that if we're being honest is
because Sue's a legend yeah she is
there are plenty of examples this of
this in in different sports but
certainly I can think of a few off the
top of my head in the NBA where the
Legends get to retire on their own terms
and maybe they weren't the player that
they were five years prior in their
Prime but they get to do it on their own
terms most of us have to figure it out
and it's a it's a very confusing process
[Music]
um
I think Sue because we you know I'm
friends with Sue as well and so like we
talked about this uh going into not only
to her last year but the year prior you
know and
I get I got the sense then and I get the
sense now like
some of it is for athletes some of it is
that identity and that drug that I
talked about like are and Sue has so
much other [ __ ] think about this Sue has
so much other [ __ ] going on she could
have been five years into her post
playing career already and be killing it
a bunch of different things yeah there's
something that is so addicting about
competing and playing a team sport and
trying to win
it's hard to give up yeah it's hard to
give up that's not when people will talk
[ __ ] about like mellow or I.T or people
they're like okay you need to retire I
get feel like they need to retire but I
also get why they can't yeah you know
and so it's just I think it's a whole
thing but I think basketball fans are
very lucky and very happy that even
though you have retired your voice is
still in it and we get to still pick
your brain and hear all your thoughts
and you genuinely are an elite
Communicator so I think that we're all
very blessed to have you in the media
space sir and to have you on my show so
thank you so much it's been fun I
appreciate it bye JJ
foreign
[Music]